dude
[Music]
I had to repair this pen the uh
metal bits in the back
came off so it's uh
re-glue those
that seems all good now
there we are
oh
so
that works
uh hope folks are doing all right
hope you're having a uh a lovely day
and uh
hope you're staying hydrated
premium pink Back in Black thank you
guys I rather like that sentiment
uh
you probably can't really tell I
actually just had a haircut today
um but it's very not it's not very
drastic compared to how I used to get my
hair done but like I got this cleaned up
and sort of
doing doing a thing back there so it's
not as much of a scraggly mess as it has
been for a little bit now
there we go
that should be better
checking
yeah
yeah I like that better
ah how's tricks I I I don't turn tricks
I don't know of what you speak
I don't know why that's where my brain
went but uh what are you gonna do
how am I I'm good I'm my brain is doing
a lot of
racing
um because I'll be leaving I'll be
leaving
on a jet plane uh for Rose City
Comic-Con uh in a couple of days and so
I'm I'm trying to already be done uh
packing as of tonight but unfortunately
a practical upshot of that is my brain
has kicked into
um that sort of scramble mode as if I
was packing to leave in like an hour and
so I'm like I'm trying to no
simmer but I'm doing pretty good
do energy drinks count as hydration
probably not but it's the southern
hemisphere that's my excuse yeah I was
gonna say I wouldn't count that
speaking personally
if I have to be trapped in a TV show for
a month what show would I choose
um
she are on the princesses of power post
season five it would be lovely
not meaning to objectify but whenever
you comment on your look being a mess
I'm like really
uh
vanity it's a thing like I honestly I
don't I don't
I'm not trying to do a self-deprecating
thing like fishing for compliments like
legitimately that this this
uh trying to grow this out it it was see
my hair starts getting wavy at a certain
length so it was hitting that length
where it was just like kind of sticking
out and trying to get it to
not look like a mess was just a pain
um now granted I generally did get it to
not look like a mess when I would
actually sit down and shoot stuff so you
haven't really seen how bad it could get
so keep that in mind too
right across um I recommended you are
very cool thank you poison heart much
appreciated I I did it as a pinned
comment this time so it's up there but a
reminder uh while I do try and keep up
with the chat the only thing that
guarantees I will see your question and
or comment is to do as a super chat
which will also get you a heart of
appreciation from me
squirrel brain is squirrel braining it
uh it do be like that
uh I finally got around to starting
stranger things and I finished the first
season it was all right ooh if you think
it was only all right I'm not sure you
should stick with it because
I don't think I'm alone in my assertion
that the first season is the best one
I think most people agree on that not
everyone agrees in how you rank the
remaining three uh for the record for me
it's
season one season three
[Music]
season two season four
I had to think about that really hard
because I don't really like season two
or season four
is it bad that I'm relieved when
conservative minority pundit slash
politician gets shut down due to
Republican bigotry and then I'm
frustrated when one hasn't been canceled
yet
ah
so it gets
it gets really messy
I I think that bigotry should be called
out regardless of the source as long as
they are not getting shut down with
attacks on their minority status
because
that if someone's actually a bad person
you shouldn't have to do that to deal
with them but yeah I think I'm kind of
there
signals rubbish you can see the chat but
not while oh try refreshing Jen I don't
know what's going on there just finished
reading haunted Burlington spirits of
Vermont's Queen City yep hope you
enjoyed it
I aspire to messy actually that's my
life philosophy in a lot of ways
so I've watched the new 40th anniversary
Blu-ray edition of the five doctors oh
very fancy Rowan they've added a proper
cartoon punch sound effect when the brig
lays the master
uh see what they should have done is
they should have pulled the full Batman
66 and actually had a little pop-up
graphical pow
so Lauren bobert has performed the worst
Alanis Morissette
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
if you get it you get it and that's good
that's good you have to get you have to
catch both halves of that reference but
if you do that's
that's good Gozer that's very good
ah
that whole thing like it it is kind of
enjoyable to see that there is a line
uh that even the uh far right
just nonsense Brigade uh will draw
uh interesting that it is based in some
way around uh sexual activity not super
surprising that that's where the line is
that's not to excuse anything she did it
was in a public study she was being rude
she deserved to be ejected and screw
that woman not except not literally I
mean like guess her boyfriend does but
you know
at
no I'm not going to say that sorry my
brain went somewhere I'm not I'm not
gonna say it though so we're gonna we're
gonna move on
um
uh I still haven't seen the Kate Bush
season yet so that's season four of
stranger things here's the thing about
stranger fourth season stranger four of
season things
here's the thing about season four of
stranger things
the parts that are good are some of the
best stuff in the show
but as I said in my review this even see
Stephen season
the stuff that's good is only about 40
percent
and the stuff that at least personally
to my taste that I didn't like I really
freaking hated
so
there's some great stuff in season four
but it's not all of it it's not even
most of it so
I still haven't seen any of my
adventures with Superman
it's not bad I wouldn't call it great
either I haven't really checked
reactions after the um
after the first few episodes so I didn't
I know it started out with a strong
impression
the other day I was
uh hold on the other day I told
oh okay I think that autocorrect messed
you up there but the other day I told
somebody that
um it's ableist when he called me an R
uh on our word yep okay both my parents
were like we do so much for you because
of your mental issues that's true but no
excuse yeah no that is no excuse
a slur term is a slur term
are you sure that's alcohol funny thing
it's actually not
legitimately this is actually water
and I will chug it to prove my point if
I need to
uh
let's see
finally working oh good I'm glad you're
seeing it now Jen
looks like Bill Marshall Barrymore will
not be uh starting their shows again
anytime soon now that it's true I'm
gonna try and have something out soon
about the fact that everybody reversed
course
um but also that it's not quite the same
in all cases uh it'll be a thing
finally finished my Master's film
Project the weird thing was despite it
wasn't intended to become uh it wasn't
intended it became weirdly relevant to
the strike as it's about robots
replacing actors in film it speaking
from experience it can be an odd thing
to be working on a piece of fiction and
have it become weirdly relevant uh as
the real world kind of forms around a
similar uh notion
not anymore Lauren dumped him oh she did
okay
bless them bring on the booger jokes
like I um
I really I really
in an epic not getting the point her
takeaway seems to be not going to date
Democrats anymore
[Laughter]
all right hell with it to to directly
forgive the curse I am about to say and
to directly quote the late great George
Carlin
God bless him I wouldn't [__] her with a
stolen dick
I'm sorry
I'm not sorry I'm a little sorry I'm I'm
sorry I felt the need to go there Dharma
thank you for re-upping the membership
21 months
lovely finally my membership is old
enough to drink haha
cheers
Captain Lunar thank you very much for
the super chat with Star Trek and Star
Wars being such juggernauts these days
I'm a Juggernaut [__]
uh even uh even more so is it weird MGM
hasn't tried bringing Stargate back
um
it is and it isn't the thing is
so how do I want to put this I have to
explain
um
executive thinking again
generally and you can see the way some
of them literally talk about how they
are under utilizing their properties how
they could be milking more money and
more projects out of this and that was
very clearly the case with Star Wars and
Star Trek because they had very big very
ravenous fan bases who you know stayed
active during dry season so clearly they
were willing to spend money
Stargate the thing is it had its
spin-offs it had its run and I think in
a lot of ways it was believed to have
burnt itself out so I think a lot of
Executives would look at something like
Stargate and not come to the conclusion
that it was being under monetized and
underutilized but rather that it was a
it was a project that ran its natural
cycle now they're probably sitting on it
waiting for the Nostalgia kick to come
around
um so I wouldn't be shocked if we got
one but I'm also not super shocked they
haven't done it if that if what I said
makes any sense I would love to meet a
ghost I don't think you would
I don't think you would miss Wicked Wolf
be very careful what you wish for and
don't mess around with that
still can't believe I'm 21 now congrats
bookworm
deities willing we all get there
eventually
uh hey Vera hope you're well just
started watching JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure it's very fun very insane very
gay something for you to check out if
you haven't already I'm aware of it I've
seen some clips of it it looks
potentially interesting but it's one of
the many many many many many many many
many many many many things on the pile
of I should get to that sometime
have I seen how the hell of a boss the
YouTube series not yet I do intend to
actually start watching that soon though
so I will get back to you on that in I
don't know a few months
uh
you're allowed to curse on your streams
I know but I try not to
apparently I don't know if this is true
the person bobert brought to the theater
was someone she'd recently met and rumor
was he was a drag queen and she had no
idea
that one I haven't heard yet
uh Supremo Mega thank you very much for
the Super Chat on revived Sidekicks ooh
it's interesting that Marvel has managed
a lot of creative mileage out of Bucky's
Winter Soldier in both comics and MCU I
wonder why well I think honestly part of
it is
Marvel doesn't really do sidekicks
Sidekicks were very common in DC you
know you had your Robins your kid
flashes your
um Speedy to Green Arrow
um uh etc etc etc you know Batman has a
whole cavalcade and most of whom could
be considered Sidekicks Marvel didn't
really do it and it's very telling that
the main character who had a sidekick
Captain America that predated the Marvel
branding which came about in the 60s
so Sidekicks weren't really much of a
thing so I actually
find it not that surprising that they
kind of poured a lot and sort of pulled
the maximum potential out of their one
very well-known sort of sidekick sort of
character
um whereas DC dropped the ball by
in the 80s into the 90s setting up these
a lot of these Sidekicks to become the
new version of X character and they were
doing Legacy characters and it was
really interesting stuff and it was
something they could do that Marvel
couldn't really do
um because they didn't really have a lot
of characters to slot into those sorts
of positions and then they rebooted with
the new 52 and messed it all up and just
lost they just lost it they lost an
awesome element of their world and it's
just gone now
so
I somehow turned an MCU and Marvel
question into a chance to dig at DC
ah there we go
geek filter thank you so much for the
Super Chat I greatly appreciate it thank
you for all your videos on the strike
they've been a great conversation
starter you are very welcome
I've had a lot more to say about it than
I had expected to
I like Stargate in theory but not in
practice way too much of let's give guns
and weaponry to these ignorant backwards
planets yeah I have to admit I never saw
any of the show uh Stargate I've seen
the movie I like the movie
um it's of its time but I do enjoy the
movie I never did see the show though
my mother said uh
uh you made sure your food doesn't give
you sensory issues it helps you get a
bed when you get too intoxicated as if
that makes it okay I mean that's just
that's taking care of someone who lives
with you that's taking care of your kid
it's always frustrating to me when
people put forward what are kind of
bare essential needs for you like I
understand that your needs might be a
little bit different from other people's
but for you these are kind of the Bare
Essentials that you need in order to
function and they're providing those to
you and that's good
but that's not leeway that's not banking
credit to be crappy about other things
which you shouldn't be treating uh
things that way anyway doing a good
thing is not uh credit towards being
allowed to do a bad thing that's not how
it should work I have a big problem with
transactional morality I went into that
a lot a year or two ago when I did my
video on
um death by Redemption as a Trope and
one of the big problems I have with it
is so often the character has done very
little to actively work to redeem
themselves and then they do this big
sacrifice of their life and like oh
because they paid the ultimate price
that that makes it all okay it's this
very transactional view of morality like
it's a balance sheet that if you do
enough good things or a big enough good
thing that it cancels out the bad things
even that's not
that's not how morality should work at
least I don't think I find transactional
morality very very unsettling as a
concept and I don't know if there's a
more commonly used term for it but I see
it a lot even though most people don't
talk about it in the terms that I do
I like your top up thank you it's just
black Captain Lunar are back again
I don't believe in goats goats
I don't believe in ghosts
but believe in demons it might be
arbitrary but I've rationalized it as if
demons exist why wouldn't they pose as
ghosts I mean that makes sense
like
all right
how far down how far into this do I want
to get
I don't know if I believe in ghosts in
the
pop culture understanding
version of what ghosts are
however I do believe that
if we if we ascribe to well the basic
um
physics Principle Energy uh and matter
cannot be destroyed or created it can
only be transformed
that's that's a fact
that having been said if you are willing
to take the step of
emotional energy being a legitimate form
of energy that maybe we cannot measure
by the same metrics but if you do
believe that that is the case
then it tracks very straightforwardly
that the emotional energy poured into
a room a building an object
can leave behind a residue
and I do think it is possible for what
that is to be interpreted by people as
ghosts
now I'm not trying to get into like a
weird metaphysical thing I'm like and if
you can if you can get the correct
reading on emps you'll prove that this
is real get the ghost hunters in there
like not stop
this is just sort of where I'm at though
like I don't believe in I don't think I
believe in ghosts in like the this
person's dead and they're still hanging
around since but I think
I have a tendency I I'm inclined to
believe that the energy that we pour
into our lives and the world around us
lingers past our physical form
let's go with that
head kittens first of all adorable name
thank you for being you oh
well thank you
I appreciate that
Netflix is making a movie off of it I'm
okay with it I want to know your
thoughts making a movie off of what oh
feeling on the Uglies Saga I know
literally nothing about it
so I have no opinion
uh uh here for the first time because
sadly too late for me usually it's 1 22
a.m in Germany right now oh you're in
the same time zone
Zer well welcome aboard
look how the Ghostbusters on your Trail
yeah
my my
tongue is not keeping up with my brain
in words tonight
learn to articulate
poison heart thank you very much for the
Super Chat I learned Disney owns Muppet
from a Tumblr reader why aren't we
getting Muppet adaptations of all Disney
properties
so
I think the thing is Disney because
Disney's owned the Muppets
for a while
they've never really fully figured out
what to do with them
they keep trying the various TV show
iterations some of which are even good
but they're not as successful as they
want them to be the the thing about the
Muppets is
The Muppets have always been a beloved
brand a nostalgic brand they've not
really ever been truly Blockbuster level
they've been ubiquitous people know who
they are but the people who really love
the Muppets are not as Broad and deep a
demographic as what Disney likes to get
out of its projects so I think the issue
is largely that Disney just hasn't
figured out what to do with the Muppets
that having been said
I would be far more open to a muppet
remake of their classic animated films
than a live action one I would still
call it unnecessary but I wouldn't find
it intellectually offensive the way I
find live action remakes intellectually
offensive so there's that
emotion is an energy as chemicals in the
brain I don't want to belittle your
beliefs but I think that's just a fact
again
we can have different views on that and
you know I said if you believe that
there is an energy behind emotions
that's a big if that's a big if and if
you don't then everything I said after
that you're not going to go with it
that's fine you don't have to go with me
to where I am
have I seen last night in SoHo nope
still haven't seen that
I would like to I like Edgar Wright but
I haven't seen it what's my favorite
scene from Family Guy oh
I honestly don't know because like there
are bits of Family Guy that'll still pop
up in my head a lot of the Cutaway gags
uh still will
I prop honestly probably the uh
the Christmas singing
um cutaway gag
all your Christmas favorites like
everybody go and look at the snow in the
yard
look at the bells look at the bells holy
crap Here Comes Jesus and he doesn't
look too happy
how bad slash uh awkward do you think
the upcoming movie about GameStop meme
stocks is going to be
um
I don't know
at its best it'll be in the neighborhood
of The Big Short which is Adam McKay's
best movie certainly and it's uh it's a
decent enough movie
um at its worst it'll just be they'll
try and make the movie itself into a
like a meme kind of thing and that'll
just be painful
uh
Muppet Lion King we had a haunted
mansion recently we did but it was It
was a
not very impressive tribute to the well
the ride more than anything else and
like I got enjoyment out of it because
it's I I fit in the very narrow overlap
of the Venn diagram of people who really
like the Muppets and also have a lot of
very specific Nostalgia for the Haunted
Mansion ride and accompanying record
that that was put out by Disney like
back in the 60s so
I did enjoy it but I don't recommend it
pigs in Star Wars
I mean Star Wars has pigs got the
grimorians I don't
I don't think uh piggy would settle for
being a henchman though
Muppets do Shakespeare
hmm
only if they're willing to fully commit
to some of the stuff that would be
uncomfortable to a family audience
Tara stahler thank you very much for the
Super Chat hey Vera I love the Stargate
TV series but one of the prequel movies
to the TV series had two token gays and
if I recall did a barrier gaze Trope I
was highly disappointed that is on
irritatingly common
but unfortunate
my previous question is basically as a
white person what are things I have to
do to depict other cultures that are not
my own and with respect
um research
do your research and even when you think
you've got it bring in a sensitivity
reader who is of the cultural background
you are trying to depict
I mean that's it
that's it learn don't guess and have
somebody come in and double check
dude
let me see
what's the worst Disney direct to DVD
sequels or Disney Live Action remates
the live action remakes are worse
there's at least some creativity in some
of the direct to DVD sequels
well you say direct to DVD it was direct
to video when they started VHS baby
any opinion on American Dad or The
Cleveland Show never really got into
either of them saw little bits there but
neither really quite worked for me
I really love how you talked about will
in your stranger things season 4 review
uh I used to feel selfish being mad that
he wasn't Ace but seeing someone who
isn't talk about it uh uh uh made me
feel better well I'm glad you were able
to relate Bruce yeah like
we do have a tendency to primarily talk
about representation of groups to which
we belong I think just for comfort you
know we don't want to accidentally step
in it but you know that doesn't make me
or anyone else incapable of seeing an
opportunity to do a certain kind of
representation that's just missed and
would have made more sense
mine's the same when Stewie beats the
living crap out of Brian for not paying
him his money with my money where's my
money
massively suppressing old new atheisters
to be like well actually uh I appreciate
your suppression
Ms Wicked Wolf quoting The Haunted
Mansion
uh if if you haven't ever heard that old
album It's shockingly morbid it's quite
good for what it is
and the uh the voice of the ghost host
is just gold
absolute gold
uh have you seen the Doctor Who Muppet
crossover in YouTube I think I did it's
been a while though I barely remember it
I think so
um opinion on Charlie's Angels I don't
really have much of one to be honest
seem to be the only person on the planet
who liked that last movie I didn't see
the second movie I saw the first one it
was okay I've seen a couple Random
episodes of the original TV show
um oh like oh God you know because they
did the reboot which had uh Kristen
Stewart and I didn't see that they did
two of the ones from the early 2000s I
only saw the first of those it was fine
I I Charlie's Angels was just very much
a product of its time like the whole
thing of like oh lady spies how novel
like it's not anymore so I don't know
what I'm not entirely sure what value
the concept has anymore just by its
nature Muppets do Corey Elena's
um
Muppet Titus andronicus
go big or go home
uh uh let me see yes the Discord
so I'm gonna check uh the Discord
questions and I will be back I will
address any super chats that come in uh
waiting at that point so bear with me
reminder the Discord is a patreon
exclusive perk and there is a channel
there where you can ask questions uh
that I will also guarantee to address
but let me see what we've got all right
we got a few in here
do you think the union should accept
Bill's backtrack this being Bill Maher
backtrack and let him hire Union writers
in the future if it was up to me I'd be
tempted to Blacklist him anyway to make
an example so I don't expect that they
will and the thing is it's more
complicated than just did he piss off
the union because uh the contract is
um going to be blanketly covered by
whatever production companies are
involved in his show I believe it is
produced directly by
um HBO uh so that would fall under
Warner Brothers Discovery so he will be
covered under any
um
blanket agreement made with that studio
which means blanket agreement with the A
and btp I believe I don't think it's
outside of the realm of possibilities of
them blacklisting individual shows but
it would be a massive thing to do and
I'm not saying he doesn't kind of
deserve it I'm just saying it it will
probably be more trouble than it is
worth to try and do just given the
nature of how the negotiations are
supposed to go at least so far as I
understand them not being an expert just
trying to do my best do you uh think you
should still support striking workers
even if they're not actually that bad
off like a few years ago I think Ryan
Ayers Pilots went on strike and I still
said I supported that strike even though
I think airline pilots are pilots
already have middle class salaries okay
well let's I don't know what it's like
in the UK I know in the US Pilots are
actually overworked and underpaid but
let's for the moment presume that the
pilots were actually paid a solid middle
class salary and I'll address the actual
body of your question
so uh yes you should still support them
because the thing is while we are used
to hearing about strikes when it is a
case of the workers are being ground so
down that they're not even making a
livable wage I believe it is fully valid
to strike if there is an increase in
profit and the workers get no part of
that
I think even if you are making a livable
wage or even a comfortable wage if the
money that the company that you work for
that benefits from your labor is growing
bigger and making more year over year
over year and the only people who get
paid more
is the people at the top or if the
amount they get paid more than you have
had a raise is completely out of
proportion like their salaries went up
300 percent and you got a five percent
raise yes strike because you are owed a
higher portion of that money even if you
are making enough to pay your bills and
everything you deserve your fair part of
the profits being generated off of your
labor you do not need to be destitute
and unable to pay your bills to have the
strike be fully valid
excuse me
do you think it's a problem that in
sci-fi and fantasy creators will often
decide who is appropriate to have a
character date based on their physical
rather than their mental age the anime
I'm watching at the moment is about a
guy who dies and gets reincarnated in a
fantasy world okay so it's in issachi uh
the thing is the writers gave him love
interests who were also teenagers even
though he remembers his past like fully
so he's mentally like 50 just by having
a 15 year old body honestly reminds me
of Edward in Twilight a little bit yeah
that
oh yeah for me personally
I'm not prepared to make a bigger nobody
should do it argument I will say that
for me no deeply uncomfortable not okay
with that not okay to read it not
comfortable with it I'm not gonna make a
blanket statement that like it's
absolutely not okay I will note though
that at the very least for as much as is
very messed up in the Twilight books and
there's a lot that is very messed up in
the Twilight boats at the very least
did the idea that his sort of mental
maturation actually locks in that
vampires don't mentally age Beyond
whatever age they were when they were
turned so not only is he physically 17
but his mental processes have never
gotten more mature and evolved any
further it was part of the justification
for why he was such a petty jerk
sometimes because ultimately he was
still a 17 year old boy with incredibly
out of date uh views on the world
which you can decide whether you think
that's BS or not but at the very least
it's an attempt to address the issue
um and again not to excuse those books
because there's a lot messed up about
those books what else we got uh what do
you like the most about going to Comic
slash TV conventions IE panels
cosplaying Etc My Favorite Things
generally tend to be cosplay just
walking the um the floor the con floor
seeing what there is seeing what's being
sold see what what vendors are there
what artists what creators
just bonding having conversations seeing
cosplay that's my favorite kind of stuff
I just like feelings surrounded by
people I share a lot of interest in
common with that just feels nice it just
feels nice
what's my favorite convention I've been
to Gallifrey one
Doctor Who convention I'm going next
year
um it's excellent and number three
insert question here oh
I feel like that one's a little personal
so I'm gonna have to pass on it
all related to The Prisoner so
for anyone who isn't already aware I am
along with Jesse gender we have paused
um the uh podcast pause the podcast
pause the podcast that we were doing on
Babylon 5 because that's a struck show
and we're currently cover covering the
prisoner the 1960s
um UK show because that is not struck
work and um we're enjoying it very much
but these are all related to that I love
the surrealism of the prisoner do you
recommend it any other works with a
similar tone not off the top of my head
because I I feel like most most more
modern stuff that I can think of that
really leans into surrealism does it
Adam does it way way harder like Legion
comes to mind that's a very surreal show
but like it's surreal down to its bone
marrow whereas I would say the depth of
surrealism and the Prisoner is more like
it's more than skin deep but it's like
at the muscle layer so I can't think of
too many other things that sort of
have it balanced to the same way because
like there is a plot to the prisoner
that you could absolutely tell without
the surrealist elements that then has
the surrealist elements laid in and I'm
struggling to think of a comparable
example I'm sure they're out there I'm
just drawn a blank
I was thinking the prisoner's mystery
without much of a planned resolution is
superficially similar to Abram's Mystery
Box concept but far better any thoughts
on that well my first thought is it is
actually
not clear if it was if it didn't have a
planned resolution that's a fairly
commonly accepted narrative partially
because of the the the debates that have
raged about the final episode and partly
because of the misconstrued story that
the episode had the finale had to be
written in a hurry
um and they couldn't do what was
originally planned there's actually very
little to support either of those
suppositions and speaking of someone
who's going through and watching it
there's Def and like I'm not going to
talk spoilers here nobody else do it
either in the chat but there are
definitely things along the way that I'm
noticing since honestly episode two that
feel like they are not directly hinting
at but are
if you know what's coming early inklings
to where it's eventually going to go in
the final episode I don't think it
I think that resolution was planned
unless somebody can find me a direct
quote from Pat mcguin himself that says
yeah we didn't know when we started I
think that was his planned ending I
honestly do
do you think a remake could work well
they already tried that and it sucked
and it you are not the first one to ask
somebody asked in my comment section A
little bit ago literally everyone seems
to have forgotten the I believe was 2009
remake of The Prisoner which is good
cause it's bad there is one phenomenal
exchange that I will always remember
it's terrific it is between
um number six and number two uh number
number two is played by Ian McKellen so
bonus points
um
number six is played by Jim Caviezel so
points deducted but anyways it's this
exchange where number two says
why won't you even open yourself to the
possibility that you are wrong
and number six says
um if I open my mind you might take it
from me and number two says we might
or we will always give it back and I
love that exchange absolutely love it
the rest of the show it's just trash
absolute trash
but uh the actual question that was
asked if so what would be the best
approach back when episodic sitcoms were
all the rage I imagine a prisoner remake
where the village was an episodic sitcom
with memory wipes
um
honestly the thing is while it is
dealing philosophically and thematically
with a lot of very big ideas about
fascism and identity and Conformity and
all these things and certainly themes
that could be Revisited now ultimately
the show very much lives in a cold war
mentality it is ultimately at least as a
background and overarching element a spy
story
in the fog of the Cold War and it really
doesn't
translate outside of that very well I
don't think maybe someone could come up
with a way to do it but honestly I think
the absence of the Cold War setting is
gonna wow it's gonna leave people
scrambling for something else to do and
do crap like the Remake did
um
or they'll just set it as a cold war
thing again in which case it's the same
damn thing so yeah I I'd be inclined to
say just leave it alone anyways I'm now
back on the uh the actual chat I've got
some super chess to catch up on here we
go Supreme
Omega in contrast to the rest of the
Trinity DC never seems to know what to
do with 1D in both comics and
adaptations for Mythos and Cass and cast
are often in flux
Wonder Woman so here's the thing
for a long time though she was
technically integrated into the main
continuity Wonder Woman was frequently
treated like her own thing
she was
um very very frequently off on her own
areas dealing with you know Greek gods
and her own Side cast and you know she'd
come in for the Justice League stuff but
they kind of treated her a bit
separately and I think honestly that was
when she was handled best but DC has
frequently not known what to do with her
they stripped her of her powers and made
her like an Espionage character
basically a black widow rip off for a
hot minute like in the 70s they had a
handle on her again in the 80s going
into the 90s then there was the New 52
version of her which is
forget my swearing dog [__]
I know everybody kind of turned on Brian
azarello after the
um
animated adaptation of the killing joke
and not wrongly but I was done with him
after trying I read three
volumes three collected volumes of his
run on Wonder Woman from the new 52.
the third one made me so angry that the
only reason I did not Chuck it across
the room into the wall was because they
were borrowed they were lent to me by
somebody else and I did not feel I had
the right to destroy them
they were
offensively bad
and I would happily go into that into
more detail but I don't want to get that
angry right now
but
that man
should not be allowed to write women
he just should not
I've heard good things about 100 bullets
uh extremely masculine focused
story as I understand it so
um you know maybe that works but do not
let that man write women
ever
Gotti pissed me sorry I'm thinking about
it now pissed me off
so much
what he did and what editorial let him
do with Wonder Woman
[__] it was bad holy [__]
oh
I'm yeah I'm I I didn't I didn't you
know what I legitimately didn't realize
how angry I still was
like I'm still
legitimately angry
about that yeah oh
poison heart also with a super chat fan
fiction Trope time travel uh
Au adult line in a child's body shipped
with an adult ah
please don't do that yeah that's that's
not real okay either like it really does
feel like it it feels like the same
thing was like oh these two were raised
together they're they they were raised
together as siblings but they're not
blood related so it's totally okay that
they start dating like no no you just
you you just you want to do a thing that
isn't okay and you're coming up with
technicalities when people write like
that it's like that character and what
was it the fourth Transformers movie who
is dating a 16 year old and he carries
around a copy of the Romeo and Juliet
law in Texas to be able to show to prove
he's not a statutory rapist
it feels like that
it's like okay technically yes but
please stop
there's a topic for an upcoming video
why was that Wonder Woman so bad maybe
I've stopped like I have
way more pent uprage about that than I
thought I did I just I started thinking
about it all again
oh oh
God
oh it's so bad
uh big finishes and prisoner audios a
few years ago I should look into those I
keep forgetting that they did that
you know what's the thing I genuinely
struggle with not telling other
Progressive their beliefs that aren't in
Practical uh that aren't and brightly
backed or nonsense
like here's here's the general thing to
my mind
you do not have to uh like I had to stop
watching a Native American who claimed
his people uh
evolved in your continent so like here's
the thing here's the thing
unless the belief is being used to
justify atrocious Behavior or unless the
belief is in it is in and of itself some
way actually harmful
I think as a general rule even if you
think someone is foolish for believing
it even if you have uh all the reasons
to say to them this is why you're wrong
if it's not hurting anybody
let them be now not all beliefs are
harmless that's the unfortunate falsity
that can grow out of that like it's just
what they believe because that's what
people throw out about JK Rowling look
she just has a belief yes she has an
actively harmful belief so like I'm not
saying beliefs are harmless because
they're not they can be very harmful but
there are beliefs
that can be wrong
but what the belief is in the way the
person guides their life by it or is
um moving forward with that belief in
their heart they're not hurting anybody
so
let them happen
uh what did you think of the way they
took Allison in season three of Umbrella
Academy honestly I'm having a hard time
remembering season three other than
Victor
and I and I remember the hotel like as a
broad concept I don't remember a lot of
what they did didn't they like go kind
of villain with her
I can't really remember now
yeah
I can't
I don't remember the details
for me with the new 52 it's Batwoman
post editorial mandate yeah I haven't
checked those out so I couldn't I
couldn't tell you have I ever seen moral
oral nope I have not
a fan of Freaky Friday then Vera here's
the thing it's been long enough since
I've seen Freaky Friday I didn't have as
fully formed my concerns and issues with
the
um
older mind and a younger body thing that
I do now so it didn't bug me at the time
and it didn't occur to me to apply that
logic to it so I actually had not
thought about Freaky Friday specifically
in that context until you said it
literally just now I would probably
enjoy that movie Less on a re-watch and
that's even setting aside the insanely
overly Deep dive I did into the ethics
of body swapping in the first place a
few years ago
yeah
uh let's see what are my thoughts on The
Flash TV show I watched the first two
seasons and got bored I got very tired
of getting pissed off at the main
character I can only do that for so long
uh it could be worse it could always be
worse everything could always be worse
that's
I I said I say this with all the
affection in my heart Dharma the phrase
that could be worse is meaningless
it could always be worse
could be better too could always be
better could always be worse
do you think the master should be rested
for uh series 14 yes honestly I think
the master should be rested
um definitely
probably the Cybermen for a little bit
too
um the dot likes
if they wanted to rest the dialects for
a bit I'd have no problem with that but
if they wanted to bring it back yeah
that's fine
um Flash Film was way worse than I could
have thought money wasted I still
haven't seen it
uh
Allison went quite villainous in season
three of Umbrella Academy because she
was in an alternate reality where her
daughter never exists and she only
joined them to do it oh right
right I forgotten about all that
um
have you yourself ever made the ass of
the nine two Electric Boogaloo crack
without having watched break in one or
two I I mean I've probably made that
joke I don't think I've ever made that
joke on camera
and I've not seen breaking one or
breaking two Electric Boogaloo
um
damn it Barry exactly Bruce exactly big
dammit Perry energy
[Music]
thoughts on the Breaking Bad show
haven't seen it but it's on the list I
like Breaking Bad that is a good solid
show has a good run starts well gets
better ends well
that's a good show I haven't seen Better
Call Saul that's another thing on the
pile
I like Supergirl TV show season one I
watched the first
four and I it's that's one of those
shows it's not like I made a decision to
stop watching I just kind of fell off
and didn't make the effort to get back
onto it
you can Believe In Unicorns no harm
forcing others to believe the same bad
well as a general rule forcing anybody
to share your belief is a Bad Thing
regardless of what the belief is like if
part of your belief involves the
forceful indoctrination of other people
into your belief then you've kind of got
a problem from first principles
wasn't the Flasher CW Show it was
I saw Freaky Friday and reminded me of
the Dr Evil line from gold member
sorry Gold Member I don't speak Freaky
Deaky Dutch
right
uh
you think a new who be great I am
hopeful I am always hoping it'll be good
um but
we'll see
Allison became a villain because of
trauma yeah I did a whole video on that
notion too I don't think I brought her
up again a lot of season three did not
stick in my head
season one stuck in my head season two
stuck in my head not that much of season
three did
yeah in spite of what I said I started
uh to construct a comment arguing you
out of believing ghosts then I was like
hypocrite
like whatever helps you sort of settle
yourself cause
look you don't have to agree with you
don't have to agree with anybody on
anything honestly but there are certain
situations where
it's not worth fighting over if that
makes sense I think that's true of
honestly all kinds of relationships be
they platonic romantic or parasocial at
a certain point
the fight is going to be bigger than the
original issue was and in some cases
like that's that's not worth fighting
fighting Legends of Tomorrow started we
got good then went downhill again I
still get upset about it I still have
not seen the last season I would argue
uh Legends of Tomorrow started out good
except for two characters got amazing
because they ditched those two
characters and I haven't seen how it
ended
the only reason I might watch The Flash
movie is from Michael Keaton's Batman I
mean honestly kind of sane
I can't remember did you ever actually
watch Doctor in distress I did
I did I did it on live stream a year or
so back
let's see
um
you ever want to hook your kid on
Shakespeare try out Star Wars rewrites
uh in his kind of meter well the thing
is my kiddo is not into Star Wars so
what if your belief is egalitarian
values well see that that's not a belief
that's a principle that's a moral
compass there is a difference between
beliefs and uh moral values those while
frequently overlapping because many
people's moral values are an extension
of their beliefs or they select beliefs
that most align with their moral values
I've seen it go both ways
um those are not automatically the same
thing so be careful about that
I meant to add it could be the spider
clone saga or the Maddie prior X-Men
thing
ah okay
so hang on let me back up
oh okay yeah
[Music]
um if you had to explain the Flash TV
show to someone in less than a minute
what would you tell them as I someone
who has never watched a full episode of
the thing great ensemble cast annoying
lead character
there you go
um
[Music]
let's see those videos you did with your
partner explaining Riverdale to you I
hope uh you do more that may or may not
happen
um Liz and I are no longer romantically
involved that having been said she has
at least hinted at the idea that she
would be willing to break my brain again
with more Riverdale so
it might still happen
we'll see
are there any Greek myth Heroes you find
compelling
Odysseus is is decently compelling
partly because of how he breaks from the
standard mold because he's sneaky and
generally the Greek heroes are very
firmly you know
that he's so strong he's so fast they
focus on the physical he's sneaky and I
like that
Drusilla is pretty uncomfortable
portrait of trauma
yeah
[Music]
I think Jerusalem has a little bit of
wiggle room in that she has the uh
apparent
some degree of psychic ability and you
could argue that that is at least a
contributing factor in what's going on
with her but yes often it is leaned on
the idea that she was basically
traumatized into being crazy which isn't
great
uh do you know the lyrics to doctor in
distress off the top my head no
uh one of the Stargate movies has this
thing called The Ark of truth that makes
everyone believe whatever you want oh
that's horrifying
that is legitimately nightmarish
uh
uh I'm off to bed but remember you're
beautiful your value are loved oh thank
you Louis
uh the character uses it to make the
character Stop Believing in the bad guys
but never acknowledge the evil potential
oh yeah no that's the kind of thing that
so basically in my mind if you're gonna
have that thing and you're going to have
the good guys use it you kind of need to
pull a Dark Knight and like have it be
used once under very circum very
specific circumstances and then destroy
it immediately
uh been trying to get caught up on the
Forgotten MCU ever watched runaways or
read it I didn't watch it and I haven't
read it
um
it's nice you two are still friends yes
it is thank you Miss Wicked Wolf what uh
made you want to grow your hair out it
looks good and I didn't like how I
looked with it so Oh you mean like just
this just this side
um experiments like I'm in my 40s now
and like if I want to find out what I
look like with a full head of long hair
when I don't feel obligated to try and
part it in a masculine way which is what
I did when I had long hair uh when I
still thought I was a dude and like just
experience having long hair in a
feminine mindset if I'm gonna do that I
should do that now not to imply that
older people can't have long hair but
you know there's a reason why the the
sort of classic
um person past a certain age look is a
shorter hair it's easier to manage so
um I'm sort of I'm taking advantage like
I want to find out
and I I have a I have a niggling feeling
in the back of my head
that I'm gonna I'm Gonna Take Years
to grow it out and get it to a length
and like the it's the full head of hair
then I'm gonna go okay
let me shave that all off again
I would not be shocked that's what ends
up happening
um do I feel Kirby and ditko deserve
more credit I mean depends on who you're
talking to the general public yeah
probably because most people know who
Stan Lee is they don't necessarily know
who Kirby and ditko are if you're asking
within
um
actual comic readers I think they are
pretty well credited at this point I
think they get the correct amount of
credit within the actual core comic book
buying audience
um but the general public yeah Kirby
especially dickco like a little bit more
not too much more a little bit more
more I don't know I'm reserved because
he was kind of an ass
um
Let's see we gotta try I gotta try and
wrap it up uh what's funny is that
Juliet Linda now seems to speak with
Drew's accent in real life interesting
yep I'll do the hyping in it in just a
moment carowind
yeah it's like that's unimaginable evil
and you didn't acknowledge at all yeah
it can be like that sometimes
anyways
so yeah we're gonna wrap it up there
thank you everybody for joining me so
I will have
hopefully tomorrow if I get the editing
done in the morning which I should be
able to I will have a video out on the
uh resuming of the various talk shows or
like the no longer resuming so Barrymore
Mar Jennifer Hudson the talk I'm gonna
I'm gonna uh deal with all that because
they've all now backpedaled restarting
the shows without writers
and then um there will be no twitch
stream at all this week
um neither Wednesday nor Friday I have
too much stuff going on and like I said
I am going to be heading out to Portland
Saturday there will be a video I may be
there for the Live premiere I may not
but that will be on
a Marvel themed mobile game that I've
been playing for eight freaking years so
uh we went light and fluffy with this
one so that'll be Saturday's video new
episode of we are all pawns uh the
prisoner podcast that will be out on
Monday and that should be everything
coming up
so thank you all for joining me very
much thank you for the super chats thank
you for the conversation thank you for
the love and please please
well first of all if you're at Rose City
Comic-Con come say hi
um but please remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
mccavity